in the first video in futures fair value
we learned that it was the price at
which an investor would be neutral
between buying the stock on the actual
stock market or buying the front month
futures contract what I want to do in
this video is talk about how does one
interpret the fair value especially
relative to the futures price so let's
say you wake up one morning the market
hasn't opened yet the stock market
hasn't opened and you see a quote like
this for stock ABCD the fair value
according to the closing of yesterday's
trading the fair value is 102 dollars
but the futures market which trades
which trades usually has trading hours
beyond the regular market and often
times 24 hours so the futures market
trading price for the front month future
even though the fair value based on
yesterday's closing is 102 the futures
market is trading it at 101 dollars so
how would you use that information or
how would one interpret that information
so in the futures market people are
trading the futures contract they're
they're buying and selling at a price
below the fair value based on
yesterday's close price so what that
means is is that the market thinks that
this is actually no longer the correct
price of the stock they think that the
correct price of the stock is the stock
at which they would be neutral between
that price and this futures contract so
I don't know what it is you would have
to discount it back by the risk-free
rate but maybe it's something like so
this is implicitly saying that the
correct price of the stock isn't $100 if
the futures price was 102 dollars it
would say that the stock should be a
hundred if the futures price is 101
dollars it means that maybe the stock is
something less than that maybe if we do
our math maybe it implies maybe it
implies a stock price of 90 maybe it
implies a stock price of $99 of 99
dollars so the way you would potentially
act on it although it's it's easier said
than done is say well look that means
that at least in the very early stages
once the market opens the stock is going
to go down now your initial reaction
might be saying wow this is really
amazing this is some type of a future
indicator and it is a pretty strong
future indicator when you see this when
you see the actual price of the future
being below the fair value it is very
likely that the stock
we'll open down unfortunately you have
many many very sophisticated
high-frequency traders who already have
their computers set up to look at this
type of a discrepancy and they're going
to be ultra fast and they're optimizing
how fast their bandwidth is so that they
can do these in a matter of split second
so it's very very very unlikely that a
that a an average investor or even a
reasonably sophisticated investor will
be able to take advantage of this type
of an arbitrage or this type of an
expected arbitrage to know that this
price is likely to go down now
if the opposite happened and let's say
that the fair value is 102 dollars which
implies the fair value of the front much
front month futures contract is 102
dollars which implies $100 stock price
let's say that the that the futures is
actually trading even though the even
though the fair value is 102 dollars
let's say that it is trading at let's
say that it is trading at 105 dollars so
this is a situation that since the
market closed the futures market for
some reason thinks that the stock is
going to be worth more this would imply
a stock price of maybe I don't know what
it might be I'm not going to do the math
exactly but maybe a price of 103 or 104
dollars and so if you saw this where the
futures price is above the fair value in
the pre-market that means that the stock
is likely to go up but once again it's
very hard to take advantage of because
you're gonna see that movement very very
very quickly